Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to
Thomas from New York? Thomas from
New York. Welcome to The David Pakman Show.
Speaker 2: Hey, David. Has it gone? Gone Well.
All right. So I'm sure you know, obviously that
Donald Trump can tell you last week that may or
may not affect Trump's run for president. But,
yes, I mean, it was when asked about Ron DeSantis,
some people say that Ron DeSantis is more of
a threat to democracy than Donald Trump is to
the multiple bills he has signed in Florida,
such as Don't take Gay Bill and his bills are
to affect elections. Yeah, my question is as if
you agree with the sentiment that Ron DeSantis is
more dangerous to the sanctity of democracy if
he were to become president rather than Donald
Trump post January six and his arrest.
Speaker 1: I generally believe so. This
is the way I kind of frame
it. If you said to me today.
Either Trump or DeSantis will be president
for four years. I think I see DeSantis as
the greater threat and would say, if those are
my choices, I would rather Trump be president
for years rather than DeSantis. DeSantis seems
much more focused, whereas Trump's brain is kind
of all over the place. DeSantis is likely to
be more effective at actually making horrible
legislative accomplishments, whereas again, Trump
gets so distracted and embroiled in controversy
that I think he would be less effective. The
counterpoint to all of this is that on the world
stage, Trump is so cartoonish and such a joke
that it might damage American reputation more to
see Trump president for another four years than
DeSantis. So it's sort of like. DeSantis would
make our reputation not quite as bad, but he would
do far more damage. Now there's another layer to
this, which you didn't directly ask about, but I
think is also important in the polling right now.
There's Trump versus Biden polling and DeSantis
versus Biden polling. Biden does better against
Trump than against the Santos. So that would be
another reason to want Trump as the nominee rather
than DeSantis, because it seems it's more likely
to lead to a Democratic president winning in 2024.
But again, this is all very early polling data.
Speaker 2: Yeah I think Trump is definitely is
a lot more cares more about his ego so he will
be less. He kind of doesn't get led as much by
the Republicans. I think Ron DeSantis is a lot
smarter and a lot more nefarious in that way.
Speaker 1: I think that's true. Thank you.
Speaker 2: I appreciate the answer.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Thomas from New York.
Great to hear from you. Got right to his question.
I mean, really a perfect phone call. Audio is
good. Just a good call in really every way.